ist tot der frühere Regierungschef
Japans stirbt nach einem Attentat das
berichten japanische Medien und die
Nachrichtenagentur Reuters
ab hält gerade eine Wahlkampfrede in der
alten Kaiserstadt naara als zwei Schüsse
fallen
der 67-Jährige wird am Hals und im
Brustbereich getroffen und bricht
zusammen sofort stürzen sich
Sicherheitsbeamte auf den mutmaßlichen
Täter ein 41-jähriger Mann wird noch am
Tatort verhaftet neben ihm auf dem Boden
die vermeintliche Tatwaffe selbst gebaut
aus zwei Rohren und Sprengstoff
laut dem japanischen Fernsehsender in HK
soll Abel kollabiert sein und einen
herz-lungenstillstand erlitten haben er
wird mit einem Hubschrauber ins
Krankenhaus gebracht wo er später seinen
Verletzungen anliegt
schon so Abel hatte Japan von 2012 bis
2020 regiert trat dann aber aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen zurück er war
der am längsten amtierende premier des
Landes